-Hi, everybody.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
Thank you so much for tuning in.
I'm Jimmy Fallon, and this is
the Roots right there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's get to the news and jokes.
Well, guys, this is exciting.
Tonight the 2020 NFL season
kicked off.
That's right. Football is back.
Finally an excuse to drink booze
and watch hours of TV.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
It's football season,
and I'll be honest.
When I saw two guys tackle each
other and make physical contact,
I got a little choked up.
[ Laughter ]
It's been so long.
That's right.
After the first tackle,
the running back didn't get up.
He was just like,
"It feels so good to be held."
[ Laughter ]
Tonight we got to see
Kansas City star quarterback
Patrick Mahomes.
Not only is Mahomes
the reigning Super Bowl MVP,
he also is
the last person to yell,
"I'm going to Disney World,"
without a hint of fear.
[ Laughter ]
That's right. It's a good time
to be Patrick Mahomes.
This summer he signed a 10-year,
$503 million contract.
When the team owner
congratulated him,
Mahomes was like,
"Actually I'm the owner now."
[ Laughter ]
$503 million.
Patrick Mahomes is so rich,
he actually bought "Mulan"
on Disney+.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, Houston's
quarterback, Deshaun Watson,
just signed his own new contract
for four years and $160 million.
When he heard that, Mahomes
was like, "Aww, that's cute."
[ Laughter ]
To keep everyone safe,
the Chiefs had just 16,000 fans
at tonight's game instead of
their usual 76,000.
It wasn't hard
to narrow it down.
They just advertised it
as a Bengals game.
[ Laughter ]
And get this --
Now all the coaches have to
wear masks on the sidelines.
You see that? Yeah.
The season just won't be
the same without seeing
Bill Belichick's
shimmering smile.
I'm just -- I just --
[ Laughter ]
Of course, another big story
this off-season was
that Tom Brady joined
the Tampa Bay Buccaneers.
This is Brady's 21st season.
21, yeah.
He's outlasted
Peyton Manning, Tony Romo,
and "Keeping Up with
the Kardashians."
[ Laughter ]
That's right. Tom Brady went
from New England to Florida.
Before, his fans pregamed
with Boston lager.
Now they do it with bath salts.
[ Laughter ]
And this is fun.
Rob Gronkowski
came out of retirement
to play with Brady
and Tampa Bay.
It wasn't a tough decision.
Once every Señor Frog's on Earth
shut down,
Gronk had nowhere else to go.
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys, everyone is still
talking about Bob Woodward's
tapes of his conversations
with President Trump.
Yesterday, Trump was asked about
downplaying the virus,
and here's what he had to say.
Yeah, Trump is a cheerleader
for our country.
Then he proved it by leading
a fun call and response
with the press.
He was like, "What do we need?"
The press was like, "A plan!"
He was like,
"When do we need it?"
"Six months ago!"
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, he's a cheerleader
for our country.
Check out his pom-poms.
Look just like the virus.
[ Laughter ]
Last night Trump complained
about the fallout on Twitter
and described it
as "the political hit job
by rapidly fading Bob Woodward
and his boring book."
Trump was like, "Total hit job.
I spoke to a reporter 18 times,
and he recorded it and wrote
down my exact words. Fake."
[ Laughter ]
Well, let's get to
some business news here.
I saw that Home Depot just made
an interesting announcement.
Listen to this.
-So, Home Depot says
they're officially canceling
that traditional rush out
to the store Black Friday.
They'll be offering discounts,
though,
through November and December
at stores and online.
-Hang on.
Were people really going to
Home Depot on Black Friday?
[ Laughter ]
People were setting their alarm
at 2:00 a.m.
and lining up outside
for plywood?
[ Laughter ]
"That's all my kid wants.
That's all he wants."
Meanwhile, T.J. Maxx will
continue their tradition
of every day
being like Black Friday.
"Give me that sweatshirt!
Give me that!
Throw it over here!"
Guys, as CBD continues
to become more and more popular,
an unlikely celebrity
has launched her own line.
Watch this.
-Hi, everyone.
I'm Martha Stewart,
and I have
some very exciting news.
I am launching a new line
of CBD products.
[ Laughter ]
-That's right.
Martha Stewart is launching
her own CBD line.
Even crazier, Snoop Dogg
is launching his own line
of tablecloths and pie tins.
[ Laughter ]
Well, here's something
we could all use.
The boxed-wine company Franzia
is now selling
a wine-dispensing backpack.
Look at this thing.
Yeah!
[ Laughter ]
Maybe it's just me,
but I'm waiting for something
a little more professional, like
a whiskey-dispensing briefcase.
[ Laughter ]
I'm pretty sure
that's the first backpack
that's for teachers,
not students.
[ Laughter ]
Some entertainment news --
during the coronavirus --
due to the coronavirus,
soap opera actors
are doing kissing scenes
but with mannequins.
[ Laughter ]
-No.
-It's a little distracting.
Watch this.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-No! What?!
-Yeah, man. That's right.
After one kiss, another
mannequin rolled in and said,
"Rodrigo, how could you?
That's my twin."
[ Laughter ]
Well, this is crazy.
A family of a missing hiker
in England
got a pretty great surprise
this week. Check this out.
-An 80-year-old Englishman
who went missing during a hike
was found safe after he walked
in on the news conference
his family set up
to try and find him.
[ Laughter ]
-Meanwhile, his wife
folded the insurance paperwork
and was like,
"Oh, good, he's back.
Thank -- Thank God.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, authorities were relieved,
while Democrats were like,
"Mr. Biden, where the hell
have you been?"
[ Laughter ]
And finally this is going viral.
Last night in Tennessee
there was a pretty interesting
sighting. Watch this.
-There is a search under way
for a tiger in Knox County.
According to
the sheriff's office,
the deputy spotted the tiger in
an industrial park last night.
No other sightings
have been reported.
-Even crazier, today the tiger
showed up at a press conference
about his disappearance.
[ Laughter ]
If you see the tiger,
be careful.
It's considered especially
dangerous ever since
it got a hold of one of
those Franzia backpacks.